there's some real utility in shouldering
the sort of responsibility that stops
you from wasting time
and you asked about negative elements of
having children yeah i feel
i think in some ways similar to russell
at least with regards to what he said so
far is
there was virtually nothing about it
that was negative as far as i was
concerned um
i suppose i i was somewhat
um it was difficult to sort out
how the attention was going to be split
in the household i missed your mother
when she was so occupied with the
infants um
but having children more than made up
for that and
you know kids get a bad rap and people
think of them as
an impediment to freedom and it's such a
foolish way of thinking because
it's so remarkable to have children and
you can have the best relationship
you have the opportunity of having the
best relationship with anyone you've
ever had in your life when you have
children
and then all also someone is finally
more
important than you you know i mean
hopefully when you get married or you
fall in love with someone they're
as important as you or perhaps even more
so
but when you have children it's
definitively the case that
now someone is more important than you
and that's
that's such a relief and it is a it is a
crucial part of maturation to have that
happen
and and i don't believe that people i'll
get pilloried for this
or maybe you will because it's your
podcast i can take the blame i can
handle it
i don't think it's possible to grow up
without having children
oh it's unlikely he's still got it
what's that i said he's still got it he
can still drop a bond mop
that's going to stir people up yeah well
i
it's hard to grow up until someone's
more important than you
so why would you why would you why
wouldn't you continue being
siberitic and and and living
at least to some degree for pleasure so
it's true but children are amazing and
so everyone out there who's thinking
about having children you should do it
because they're
they add they add to your life and then
when you're older like me i'm 60 almost
60 now
i have grandchildren now and i can't
imagine what
my life how empty my life might be
without
that and more of that on the way so
yeah i know some rather brilliant people
as i'm sure
you both do that have a foregone or
decided against or unable to have
children
i suppose the values that brought to the
surface in parenthood
perhaps duty devotion
and perhaps if there is a sort of some
transcendent component to your life and
i don't mean that in necessarily in a
spiritual
way but it's difficult to avoid the
connotations of that word
then perhaps perhaps maturation
is possible if you take for example like
a straightforward
mendicant's life monasticism
celibacy devotion in a very uh
explicit way to god then would you
say that they are unable to to reach
maturity or what if it was a secular
version like devotion to the arts or to
a sort of a political cause do you not
think that that could
well of course i know that's reminds me
of something i wanted to talk to you
about i read your book
mentors which is this book right here
and um
one of the things that it made me think
about was
i've thought for a long while that
the one of the processes that marks the
transition from
childhood to adulthood is apprenticeship
and so one of the things nietzsche said
about the catholic church was that
the european mind this is speaking in
nietzsche's voice the european mind
disciplined itself
by adhering to a single interpretive
strategy for centuries
to explain everything under the
conditions on
to explain everything using the axioms
of a single
intellectual system and that disciplined
the european mind and enabled it then to
go off and
use other disciplinary strategies to
discover other
to discover other ways of dealing with
the world maybe to develop science for
example and
nietzsche was very convinced that you
had to enslave yourself in one manner or
another before you could be free
and that's an apprenticeship motif and
to me that's what you explored
in your book mentors you know you you
present yourself i believe as someone
who was striving in various ways to
mature and that you identified people
who came into your life as targets for
emulation that could impose a discipline
on you and help you mature you would
hunger for that like like people do and
yes i do think that
if you don't have children there are
other disciplinary strategies
that you can use to further your
maturation but it isn't obvious to me
that any of them are as
profound as having children and i mean
i've had a good career and
i've been very interested in
intellectual pursuits as well and
i suppose have disciplined myself in
some manner because of that but
i still stand by my um statement about
children
they're in a different category of of
profundity
it's partly because you have to take on
so much responsibility when you have
children
is it the sacrifice too i mean if you
think about people who
who work in churches or what russell is
saying about
you know people who devote themselves to
god and it's kind of what they do is
kind of sacrificial and i suppose part
of what you do
when you have kids is sacrifice that
hedonistic
part if you're going to be a good parent
so
is is part of what helps you mature the
sacrifice associated with having
children or is it something else
i don't know if that's part of what
helps you mature or if that's a
definition of maturation
is that it's a sacrificial act but you
know people
often think of sacrifice in terms of
loss but
the reason you sacrifice fundamentally
is to gain something higher
that's that's the sacrificial motif you
give up something that's
that's attractive in the present but but
the purpose of the sacrifices
is to is to
to organize things more effectively at a
higher level of being
so and that is a that is maturation that
that's the forestalling of immediate
pleasure for
medium to long-term um well-being and
maybe for more than you as well
okay um
i have a question even though i know
it's not my podcast
and when you transduce a metaphysical
idea like sacrifice
and sacrifices as an evocation of a
greater power further down the line and
you
transduce it into materialist and
rational rationalist terms perhaps to
make it more relevant
to a cultural group that don't
think in that way anymore do you think
that
we risk missing part
and the essential part of the mystery
that much of the devotional life
by its nature doesn't have a a direct
uh translation in secularism
i.e of course yes you know i've heard
you say before
jordan that it's as if there were a
father that's a stern father that's
going to guide you
and discipline you and chide you into
being a stronger man or woman
but like um but i feel too
that there is something that what
through sacrifice we are also
acknowledging that on this plane of
being on this plane
of being all our needs cannot be met in
fact really all we can do is generate
need and by sort of sacrificing food or
sacrificing
like sacrificing something important we
reaffirm our connection to the sublime
okay well i think that whenever you
bring a transcendent concept in some
sense down to earth
you risk inappropriately constraining it
if you assume that your act of bringing
it down to earth has
explained it fully so
i don't believe that my explanation of
sacrifice explains it
fully and so i think you can retain that
you can retain the enough you can retain
the advantages of ineffability
for example if if i assess a
piece of literature or film for
and make its metaphysical presumptions
more explicit i don't believe that that
necessarily takes away from the film it
it can because it can be reductionistic
but it can
add an additional by furthering
understanding it can add an additional
layer of
of utility to the to the experience
i've tried to do that with the biblical
lectures i've done
for example i i'm not trying to explain
everything away
although i do think that generally
speaking you should use the simplest
explanation that's at hand
so it's a risk but but
hopefully it can be a a risk that is
fundamentally productive
yeah i reckon i said i suppose that
mentorship and
education is dependent on crossing this
space
between the ineffable and the at least
palpable or
the apprehendable justice is that if the
ineffable stays entirely ineffable then
you can't put it to use
and i think you're absolutely right that
the mentorship does that because
and there's a profound religious
instinct there and i think it was really
operating in you
you you make reference to it a number of
times for example you have
by your own admission a strong tendency
to
um romanticize the women in your
in your life you say you deify them in
some sense or maybe more accurately you
perceive them that way to begin with and
then
over time in some sense the stars fall
away from your eyes but that's the
action of an instinct that would be the
anima projection from a union
perspective is that
there's a an instinct in you that's
pushing you towards development and the
way it manifests itself is by
illuminating
certain elements of your experience and
those might be
that might occur for example when you
meet a male figure
who you admire who you then start to
imitate it's it's
the deep workings of your unconscious
illuminate that figure and make
him say stand out against the background
because you've apprehended that there's
something about his pattern of being
that addresses a lack in yours and the
same thing
can happen in romantic relationships and
and that can
also not be purely illusory
you know in some sense when you when you
have a romantic relationship with
someone
you are chasing the divine in each other
now both of you may fall short
and the relationship may fall apart but
by seeing the divine in the person that
you fall in love with you also
invite them to manifest that and by
opening the door to that
they're actually more likely to manifest
it it's
very complex it's very complex and
sophisticated instinct
i understand this i understand this i
have experienced this i recognize that i
have
spent a lot of time projecting through
my inability to comprehend my own
psychic energies i've projected onto
another
resources that were available perhaps
through tutelage
within myself one of the mentors that i
write about in that book who's like
has been incredibly valuable in my life
when we first met like
by you know synchronicity or chance gave
me a copy of
the robert johnson's book on gold and in
a gold
which is a sort of an essay on
mentorship and have it you know holding
one another's goal
um and i think yes that
how mentorship has functioned in my life
has
i've gained a great deal of perspective
i've understood that they are kind of uh
psychic cynic decays
holding for me a space holding meaning i
recognize the fallibility of these
people
that i uh like adore or aspire to
um but in my psyche they function as
coordinates i was just talking to a
brilliant therapist today
in therapy and like a and he said that
you know that
you don't need to overcome your father
and mother
in the physical world with them you need
to overcome the imprint of them
in your psyche and i said yes in a sense
they are hollowed out carapaces in
reality i don't mean that of any
disrespect to my actual mother and
father
but like the the mother and father that
i deal with and live in my psychic
landscape they don't live
in essex england you know um
so like i recognize yes that we can use
relationship as an external coordinate
to activate
dormant psychic energies
so there's a kind of reductionism in
that too in some sense right because
by by by doing that you reduce the
the the experience of the divine in
someone else to activation of an
unconscious
um um complex let's say but one of the
things you point out in the book
and and it's possible to go deeper than
this too one of the things you point out
in the book is that
when you allow or ask or invite someone
to be your mentor
you also allow them to manifest that
element of them that's most
mentor-like and they can do that
independently to some degree
of their other flaws just like when
you're a parent a father
you can act paternally as a figure of
authority even though
you are by no means a perfect figure of
authority
the child still needs you to be the best
authority figure
that you can be despite your flaws and
and you will manifest that
but it it that's also
not false because
the ideal that we're all chasing we we
don't know
what its ultimate reality is you know if
you have an instinct towards further
development let's say
what that means is that there's
something about you that
could be greater than it currently is
and we don't know the limits to what
that currently greater
could be and that's where the
the idea of mentorship let's say shades
into something like religious worship
because i suppose
if you think about the christian world
the ultimate mentor is christ
and you could say that being a christian
or you could say that being a
psychologist and
if you said it being a psychologist you
would say well it's by definition that
the ultimate mentor is christ
and what christianity has been as it
unfolds itself over the last
two thousand years is an attempt to
engage all of the people within that
belief system in a dialogue about what
that
ideal actually constitutes you know when
there's tradition that feeds into that
the biblical stories and and the corpus
of tradition that goes along with that
but
all of it is a collective attempt to
specify that ideal
so that people can use it as a target to
further their development
and that's not delusional that that
furthering of development is
unbelievably useful practically